sometimes countries don't get along and
when in 1960 the soviet union and the
people's republic of china decided to go
their separate ways the vast majority of
communist countries threw their lot in
with the ussr
with the exception of one albania but
given albania's proximity to the ussr
and that picking china would leave it
isolated in the socialist world
why did it choose to go with them why
did albania side with mao
so albania became communist in the wake
of the second world war
in 1946 the albanian monarchy was
abolished which left the current prime
minister and vahja as the unquestioned
leader of the country
at first he had good relations with
yugoslavia except for one area of
contention
kosovo which many in albania wish to be
incorporated into the country
naturally yugoslavia said no but given
yugoslavia's influence over the country
hoja just had to deal with it
this was until the yugoslavia instead of
falling out with the ussr and so hoshi
opted to capitalize on this and sided
with stalin who offered albania both
protection and lots of economic aid
whilst hoja purged everyone in the
government who was pro-yugoslavia the
thing with stalin was that he was mortal
and his successor nikita khrushchev soon
reduced aid to albania
and he further demanded that hojo reform
his government to move away from
stalinist policies
hoshi believed that khrushchev was weak
and his reforms and desire to coexist
with the west would mean the end of
communism
relations between the ussr and albania
slowly worsened until 1960 which was
when mao and khrushchev had their own
falling out over soviet foreign policy
the chinese denounced the soviets as
weak fake communists and hoja sensed
another opportunity whereby he sided
with mao
hoja now openly called the ussr corrupt
and tyrannical
and one of the reasons he was
comfortable doing this was that because
unlike poland and hungary the soviets
couldn't invade albania without going
through another state
and also hoshi had built like a billion
defensive bunkers to help repel any
invasion
after this hoshi built up good relations
with china who began to provide aid and
protection to albania whilst hoshi
purged the government of anyone who was
pro-soviets
and china provided this aid in
protection to albania despite its own
economic woes because albania could
provide something which the people's
republic of china didn't have
a seat in international negotiations
china had a seat on the u.n security
council at this point
however this china was the republic of
china based entirely in taiwan whereas
the rest of china got nothing
as such albania could raise issues on
behalf of the beijing government such as
constantly asking for a vote on
recognising mao was china's legitimate
leader
which eventually passed in 1971. prior
to this the latest soviet leader leonid
brezhnev had tried to heal his country's
relationship with albania but hodger
wasn't interested
and the end of this relationship was
formalized in 1968 when albania withdrew
from the warsaw pact after its
intervention in czechoslovakia
which he could openly do because again
bunkers
after this albania continued its path of
close alliance with china
that was until the americans came
knocking this saw richard nixon improved
relations with china which soon opened
up four more ties with the usa
and the two countries began a period of
increased cooperation based on trade and
not liking the ussr
to hoshi this was a betrayal and he
denounced chinese leadership and again
he switched sides and purged the
government of n1pro china
this time though the side he picked was
albania's side
chinese aid to albania soon dried up
leaving it without any major protector
and this saw the country enter a period
of international isolation which would
last all the way until hodge's death in
1985.
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bisonette mr wolfe kelly money
maker skye chappelle rob d martin
captain cydog marvin cassell moe aaron
the white adam stalter jordan longley
boogerly wuggly gustav swan jerry lamdin
rasheed ali gareth turner maggie
patzkowski coppertone winston k wood
spinning three plates corso wolff
marcus asner spencer lightfoot matthew
shipley the mug whopper alex schwinn
lil brepantisi robert wetzel anthony
beckett charles the first and scottish
trekkie